AND I PUT A LITTLE BIT MORE -- A
LITTLE WORK, SO I THINK
COMBINING EVERYTHING TOGETHER.
>> JOKER, SHAQ HERE.
YOU'RE THE FIRST BIG MAN TO WIN
THE MVP IN A LONG TIME.
I THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE YOU
VERY MUCH.
COMING FROM SERBIA AS A KID, DID
YOU EVER SAY TO YOURSELF I WILL
BE AN MVP AND IN THE NBA ONE
DAY?
>> NO.
TO BE HONEST, LIKE, I DIDN'T
EVEN THINK ABOUT BEING IN THE
NBA, YOU KNOW?
MY GOAL WHEN I STARTED TO PLAY
BASKETBALL BACK WHEN IT WAS
PLAYING EURO LEAGUES BECAUSE
THAT WAS THE CLOSEST TOP LEAGUE
TO MY COUNTRY, YOU KNOW?
I CAN PLAY IN SOME BIG CLUBS IN
SERBIA AND KIND OF GRIND MY WAY
UP, BUT THEN WHEN DENVER
NUGGETS -- THE DENVER NUGGETS
DRAFTED ME, IT WAS -- IT WAS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR ME TO BECOME AN
NBA PLAYER AND I THINK I DID A
GOOD JOB OF USING THAT
OPPORTUNITY.
YOU KNOW?
>> NIKOLA, NUMBER ONE,
CONGRATULATIONS.
WHO WAS THE FIRST COACH WHO MADE
YOU BELIEVE IN YOURSELF?
HE SAID, NO, YOU'RE GOING TO BE
A GREAT PLAYER.
BECAUSE THERE IS ALWAYS A COACH
WHO GIVES YOU THAT SUPREME
CONFIDENCE.
WHAT COACH WOULD YOU LIKE TO
THANK FOR GIVING YOU THAT
SUPREME CONFIDENCE?
>> TO BE HONEST, EVERY COACH
THAT I HAVE REALLY GAVE ME A
FREEDOM TO DO KIND OF MY THING,
YOU KNOW?
SO EVERY COACH GAVE ME AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SHOW MY SKILL SET
OR WASEVER.
BUT THE KIND OF COACH WHO REALLY
TELL ME MVP AS AN' AWARD IS
FELIPE, HE WAS ONLY ONE OF --
ONE A HALF YEAR AGO, TWO YEARS
AGO, HE WAS TELLING ME MVP, MVP,
MVP.
HE WAS KIND OF THE FIRST GUY WHO
LET IN MY BRAIN, I CAN SAY LIKE
THAT.
>> YOU KNOW, CONGRATULATIONS ON
BEING THE MVP OF THE NBA.
IT SOUNDS KIND OF OVERWHELMING,
BUT THERE HAD TO BE A POINT,
LIKE YOU SAID, YOU DIDN'T THINK
ABOUT THAT, BUT AT WHAT POINT IN
THIS SEASON DID YOU LOOK AROUND
AND SAID, MAN, THIS COULD BE IT.
WAS THERE A PARTICULAR POINT
THAT HAPPENED?
>> THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THIS
YEAR, I THINK I STARTED THE
SEASON REAL WELL.
I MEAN, WE ENDED A SEASON AND WE
HAD A REALLY GOOD SEASON LAST
YEAR AND WE HAD A MONTH, TWO
MONTHS REST I CAN SAY.
I STARTED THE SEASON REALLY
WELL.
AND I PLAYED -- I PLAY KIND THE
WHOLE SEASON REALLY WELL STAT
WISE, YOU KNOW.
I THINK THIS WAS MY BEST SEASON
OF MY LIFE AND KIND OF THE
CHERRY ON TOP IS PROBABLY THE
TROPHY THA